cloud shell editor makes it easy for you
to write code directly in your web
browser and deploy it to the cloud
and cloud run makes it easy to deploy
highly scalable containerized
applications on a fully managed
serverless platform
so you might be wondering can i write
the code for my cloud run apps
in cloud shell editor yes you definitely
can
thanks to its cloud code integration
cloud shell editor works great with
cloud run development workflows
allowing you to build deploy and debug
your application in just a couple of
clicks
in this video we're going to see how to
use cloud shell editor to deploy an
application to cloud run
let's go first visit
ide.cloud.google.com
to launch the cloud shell editor on the
status bar at the bottom of your screen
click cloud code from the cloud code
menu
click new application and then select
the cloud run application for the type
of sample app we want to create
after that we'll get a list of cloud run
templates to choose from
let's go with the python flask option
next
select a folder in your cloud shell
environment to save your application to
and give it a name if that looks good
click create new application
cloud shell editor clones the files for
your sample application from github into
a new workspace
you can see the list of files in the
explorer panel located on the left side
of the screen
now let's go ahead and deploy the
service let's go down to the status bar
again
and click cloud code this time we'll
click deploy to cloud run
click authorize to authorize cloud shell
to make google cloud platform api calls
to give cloud shell editor access to
your google cloud resource
since this is the first time using cloud
run on this project we're prompted here
to enable the cloud run api
in the deploy to cloud run dialog under
service settings we can set the name for
our service
and under deployment we can select the
region we want it to be deployed to
since we want to make this a public
service we'll keep allow unauthenticated
invocation selected
[Music]
there are some additional settings we
can adjust like container settings
environment variables and cloud sql
connections
there are also build settings where you
can choose your builder from docker and
build packs
for now we'll leave those as their
default values and click deploy
cloud code now builds your image pushes
it to the container registry
and deploys your app to cloud run once
you see the message deployment completed
successfully
your service is live and accessible via
the url displayed in the deploy to cloud
run dialog
that was pretty easy and updating your
cloud run app is just as simple
let's redeploy your app with an update
to this message
back in our cloud shell editor from the
explorer panel let's open the file
app.py
in the hello function we'll find the
message variable that holds the friendly
http greeting we just saw
let's update that message
[Music]
cloud shell editor automatically saves
all file changes
once we make our changes we can head
back down to cloud code
down in the status bar once again
let's click deploy to cloud run
this time the service we created before
is listed here in the service settings
let's hit deploy to deploy our updated
service
once it's done we can head back to our
deployment url and refresh the page
and there it is our app has been
redeployed with the updated code
with just a couple of clicks we are able
to deploy update and redeploy a simple
cloud run application
and we are able to do it all directly
from our browser window
without having to leave our cloud shell
editor
do you want to give it a try yourself
check out the interactive tutorial
linked in the description below
or by launching it from the cloud shell
editor welcome page
for more videos on cloud shell editor
and a whole lot more make sure to
subscribe to the channel
join me next time when i'll show you how
easy it is to use cloud shell editor to
deploy to google kubernetes engine
see you there
you